mrs grange's second grade class has 45
tennis balls whenever i do a word
problem like this i just like to write
down the information that they're giving
me so we're going to start with
45 tennis balls
they then tell us that 19 tennis balls
so she starts with 45 tennis balls to
play with at recess did they tell us
that 19 tennis balls get thrown over the
fence
and six tennis balls just disappear
how many tennis balls does miss grange's
class have left so what i'd like to do
these type when i when i do these type
of word problems i'll say okay first of
all where am i starting from well i'm
starting from 45 tennis balls and then
what's happening am i gaining tennis
balls or am i losing tennis balls well i
started with 45 or ms grange's class
started with 45
then 19 tennis balls get thrown over the
fence so they're losing the balls and
then another six tennis balls disappear
so both of these are losing tennis balls
and since i'm losing something since i'm
losing the tennis balls or some of the
tennis balls that i started with i
should subtract here another clue that
subtraction might be interesting is
because it says how many test balls does
miss grange's class have left which
implies that well she doesn't have all
the tennis balls that she started with
so we're probably going to subtract some
balls but it comes straight out of the
word problem 19 tennis balls get thrown
over the fence she loses them so we
should subtract that from the original
amount and then another six just
disappear so we should then subtract
that on top of the 19. so let's do that
so let's first subtract the 19.
so we started with 45 tennis balls
and then 19 balls get thrown over the
fence
so
19 get thrown over the fence so we're
subtracting them they lose those balls
so what is this going to be
well if we look in the ones place we
have five ones minus nine ones since
five is less than nine we wanna do some
regrouping so let's go to the tens place
instead of four tens let's write that as
three tens and then take that ten turn
into ones so it's going to be ten ones
ten ones plus five ones
is fifteen
now we're ready to subtract fifteen
minus nine well that's going to be six
because nine plus six is fifteen
and then three tens minus one ten is
going to be two tens
so twenty six but are we done
no this is just the number of balls we
have left after the 19 get thrown over
the fence but before we we count the six
that just disappeared so we also have to
take away six for the six balls that
disappeared so let's do that
so after 19 so we started with 45
19 get thrown over the fence
you have 26 at that point
then
six balls just disappears once again
they disappear they're not they're not
you know magically appearing
since they're disappearing we subtract
so we they're disappearing so we want to
subtract those so how many do we have
left
well six ones minus six ones is zero
ones
two tens
minus well nothing here that's just
going to be two tens so how many do we
have left
well or how many does does miss mrs
grange's second grade class have left
well you see it right here they have
they have 20
tennis balls
20 tennis balls left started with 45 19
get thrown over the fence so they lose
them that's why we subtracted that gets
us to 26 and then six of them disappear
so we take the six away from the 26 to
get to 20.